(clichés photo)
- Les deux hommes
ne se font pas confiance,
et même lors de la poignée
de main, un léger malaise.s s se
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Antony Blinken et son homologue
russe Sergueï Lavrov.
qu'une invasion est possible?"
"À moins que les États-Unis
n'aillent au lit avec l'Ukras s.
Sur le terrain, la tension est
grande : plus de 100 000 soldats
russes sont toujours postésaiai.
Et il y a également beaucoup de
mouvement des forces russes au
Bélarus, au nord de l'Ukraine,e.
Des navires militaires russes
seraient également en route.
Bref, une attaque seraitelelele-
Blanche.
Les États-Unis ne veulent pas
revivre le même scénario202020ùe
a annexé la Crimée.
"Nous nous engageons à
poursuivre la voie diplomatique
dit-il, mais si cela s'avère
impossible et que la Russie
poursuit son agression
sera sévère et rapide."
Moscou maintient la même
demande : un non-élargissement
de l'OTAN à ses portes
et surtout réclame que
l'Ukraine ne fasse pas partie
de l'organisation.
"Nous attendons des réponses
obligations qui ont ét
au sein de l'organisation pour""
Moscou veut des g
par écrit des Américains.
aux inquiétudes so
par la Russie, dit-il,cher
l'Ukraine de feeeeee
de l'OTAN."onononononononononond
à tout et a ln n n n n n que
l'avenir de l'Ukraine se négocie
et la Russie.
"Ils négocient entre eux,
dit-il. L'Ukraine n'est
"Nous avons peu de pouvoir
et d'influence, dit celui-ci.
Il n'y a même pas assez
en Ukraine pour qu'ils s'en
soucient."
En attendant, la Grande-oyoyoys
missiles anti-chars à l'Ukraine,
et les Américains viennent de
donner le feu vert aux Étatsvovs
anti-aériens Javelin et Stinger
à l'Ukraine.
Les deux hommes se sont
pourparlers la semaine prochainu
que le président américain
s'en
Vladimir Poutine.
Et pour Joe Bid
un autre test sur sa politique
étrangère avant les électt t t s
la débacle en Afghanistan
lors des retraits des troupes
américaines; cette fois,
aucun signe de faiblesse.
ldldldldldldldlde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Washingto